hey shoot all the guys while i do the
thing
oh hey hi welcome back so
destiny according to activision it's
grossed over 325 million dollars and
racked up over 100 million hours of
playtime online but it's not a game
without flaws and many people have been
quick to criticize it for being quite a
limited experience albeit a polished one
so how can something that so many people
find mediocre be so commercially
successful well whenever we talk about
the popularity of games the conversation
inevitably gets dragged in the same
beaten path oh it's it's just the
fanboys that love it reviewers are
corrupt and critics are all hipsters
well things in life are very rarely
explained away in the stroke of a
keyboard and though there might be
specific reasons why destiny in
particular is divisive i feel like the
fallout from the game's reception is
emblematic of a much wider trend than
games
the point season 3 episode 1 destiny
review and aging gamers
i'm 28 years old and though i'd like to
say i'm still young at heart my
experience as a games enthusiast are
based entirely on the era i grew up in
when i was six and first fell in love
with computer games the year was 1992
and i was playing on my commodore amiga
600 the first game i ever completed was
the secret of monkey island it came on
four floppy disks and had blocky but
charming graphics one of my friends had
a nintendo and was enjoying the legend
of zelda a link to the past another
friend had a pc which is why i first
played this awesome strategy game called
dune 2 and the game that kick-started
the first person shooter genre
wolfenstein 3d
these were great games that while being
challenging and entertaining filled us
with wonder wonder about these new
worlds we were exploring and wonder
about the future of video games flash
forward six years it's 1998 and i'm now
12 years old enjoying the fruits of a
quickly evolving media this is the year
that saw the release of starcraft
ocarina of time thief the dark project
grim fandango metal gear solid boulder's
gate fallout 2 and half-life in six
short years the world of video games had
evolved into a form almost
unrecognizable from when i first entered
it adventure games went from blocky 2d
text affairs to fully 3d experiences
with voice work and cd quality audio
first person shooters from pixelated
corridor crawlers against idiotic
enemies to atmospheric stealth
experiences and action-packed sci-fi
dramas against foes who used cover
tactics and strategy hyrule was in 3d
real-time strategy was in esport
controllers now had dozens of buttons
you could play on the internet and where
2d approximations of places once stood
there were fully realized 3d worlds to
explore and this evolution continued in
the mere six years following that
top-down gta had evolved into massive
san andreas half-life evolved into
physics-powered half-life 2 and a year
later in 2005 we took our first steps
into hd console gaming
that was 2004 and as hard as it might be
to imagine it it's been a decade since
then doom 3 turned 10 years old during
the summer world of warcraft will
celebrate double figures on november
13th while half-life 2 will do so three
days later and in those 10 years though
we've played some absolutely incredible
games games that have done new things
and explored new mechanics and themes
the rate of evolution from the medium as
a whole is incomparable with what those
of us in our late 20s and beyond
experience growing up it's fair to say
that games are in their teenage years in
terms of technical evolution we've
clearly hit the point of diminishing
marginal returns games have been played
on broadband internet for a decade
they've been downloadable for a decade
we've had most of the same genres for
that period of time too where once we
saw series evolve in ways we couldn't
have imagined over the course of seven
short years we now see entire franchises
come and go and look basically pretty
much the same i'm very fortunate to have
been part of a spoiled generation of
gamers a generation that was there as
games took over the world who saw
franchises rise from obscurity into
global blockbuster brands we've seen
games evolve so much that we demand they
continue to do so and we hate it when
they don't what's my point i guess it's
that i imagine the world of games is
very different place for those of you in
your teens or early 20s i imagine the
things that you want from video games
are pretty different to me the older i
get the more i crave new experiences
that remind me of those halcyon days on
my amiga or playstation that's why i
gravitate towards some games and feel
apathetic towards others that's why we
all do so whether it's destiny or gone
home or fifa or far cry my opinion your
opinion everyone's opinion has weighed
so heavily against the games that we
played growing up and the things we
desire in our games today there was a
time when you could play most great
games where there was a consensus in our
culture over what was good and bad but
today we all come from such wildly
different gaming heritage that to try
and find consensus is a fool's errand
yet still in review comments on message
boards on twitter we're all screaming
the one true opinion when really more
than ever before there simply isn't one
so perhaps the problem isn't that some
gamers are jaded or overly socially
conscious perhaps the problem isn't that
other gamers are less discerning or
misogynist fanboys maybe we all just
want something different from the games
we play and if we learn to accept that
like we seem to have been able to do
with film and television and music and
books then we'd all be at each other's
throats a lot less whatever consensus
there used to be in games is long gone
so let's just stop pretending it exists
and love whatever games we want
you